dos pruebas se utilizan para la
detección del cáncer de cuello uterino
la prueba de papanicolaou y la prueba de
vph el cuello uterino es la parte
inferior del útero ubicado en la parte
superior de la página
una prueba de papanicolaou se utiliza
para detectar la presencia de células
anormales en el cuello uterino las
células anormales pueden a veces
desarrollar cáncer cervical si no se
tratan en algunos casos también es
probable que se analicen las células
para detectar una posible infección
causada por un virus llamado virus del
papiloma humano vph el vph es la causa
de la mayoría de los casos de cáncer
cervical así como de las verrugas
genitales
se pueden obtener células para ambas
pruebas durante un examen pélvico en
primer lugar el proveedor de atención
médica colocará un instrumento llamado
especuló en la vagina el espéculo se
abrirá de manera que se pueda observar
el cuello uterino a continuación el
médico usará un raspador o cepillo para
suavemente recoger células del cuello
uterino
las células serán examinadas bajo un
microscopio en un laboratorio para ver
si alguna de ellas es anormal el
laboratorio también puede analizar las
células para ver si muestran signos de
infección por vph
por lo general lleva de una a tres
semanas obtener los resultados de la
prueba
si tiene preguntas sobre estas pruebas o
sobre los resultados de las pruebas
habla con su proveedor